نعم نحن الان في قلب مدينه جنديرس في هذا
المكان التي تم الذي تم اختياره لبناء
مخيم
للعوائل المتضرره نتيجه هذا الزلزال طبعا
سيتم
استضافه العائلات في هذه في هذا المخيم
الذي سيتم بناءه وتامينهم وتامين لهم سلل
اغاثيه ومستلزمات الخيمه طبعا هذا المخيم
يتم بناؤه ضمن الحمله المملكه العربيه
السعوديه من قبل مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه
احد عشر شاحنه دخلت الى الداخل السوري
وتوجه قسم كبير منها الى مدينه جنديرس هذه
المدينه التي نالت النصيب الاكبر من اعداد
الضحايا والدمار في شمال غرب سوريا طبعا
هذه الشاحنات دخلت من بعد ان وصلت الى
مطار غازي عنتاب جزء من سته طائرات وصلت
الى هذا المطار اللي الحديث اكثر حول مصير
هذه المساعدات وكاليه توزيعها دعيني ان
استضيف معي السيد ياسر طراف وهو منسق
الاستجابه الطارئه في الجمعيه الدوليه
لرعايه الضحايا الكوارث والحروب الامين
اهلا وسهلا بالبدايه سته الطائرات وصلت
الى مطار غازي عنتاب دخل منها 11 شاحنه
ممكن نحكي عن اليه التوزيع عن عدد يعني
الحاجه الاساسيه هون هي الخيم بناء ماوى
كيف راح تتم الاستجابه طبعا بدايه بحب
اذكر انه اول شيء الطائره دخلت من خلال
معبر جوي اغاثه بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وبين تركيا طبعا هذه الطائرات
دخل منها الى سوريا قافيه واحده اللي هي
عباره عن 11 شحنه بقيه الحملات حيث يتم
توزيعها بين سوريا وبتركيا بالنسبه للجانب
السوري فاللي دخل هو عباره عن 11 شاحنه من
خلال معبر الحمام الح تركيا هاي الشواحين
تتضمن عده مواد اللي هي مواد غذائيه خلال
غذائيه ومواد غير غذائيه اللي هي طبعا
كانت عباره عن خيم وسلال واغطيه
للناس اللي ضررت يؤثر الزلزال اللي صار
جنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا طبعا هاي
الموادعها بمناطق ادلب ومناطق عفرين احنا
حاليا متواجدين بوسط ناحيه جنديرس عم نقوم
ببناء واحد المخيمات طبعا هذا المخيم رقم
ثلاثه اللي احنا عم نباشر فيه ان شاء الله
وغدا الفرق راح تكون متواجده بمناطق ادلب
لا ان شاء الله رب العالمين حنحاول نوصل
لاكبر عدد ممكن من الناس اللي ضررت خلال
الفتره القادمه